Tenemos que simplificar
7x más 10 al cuadrado. Ahora uno puede estar muy tentado a decir que eso es igual a
7x al cuadrado más 10 al cuadrado
pero, eso está muy mal, es una equivocación que uno suele hacer al principio pero está muy mal ¿Ok?
Aquí tenemos un paréntesis y estamos elevando al cuadrado a
todo el paréntesis, y elevar al cuadrado
significa que tenemos que multiplicar a todo el objeto que estamos elevando al cuadrado, que en este caso es
7x más 10.
Todo este paréntesis lo tenemos que multiplicar por sí mismo otra vez,
¿Ok? Tenemos a 7x más 10 y elevarlo al cuadrado, es lo mismo que
volverlo a multiplicar por otro 7x más 10.
Es cierto que en algunos casos por ejemplo, cuando tenemos
7x por 10 y queremos elevar esto al cuadrado.
Nótese que aquí estamos sumando y aquí estamos multiplicando,
y entonces estas 2 cosas no son la misma cosa pero, bueno en este caso esto si es igual a
7x al cuadrado por 10 al cuadrado ¿Ok? Pero eso es por que estamos multiplicando,
entonces al elevar al cuadrado lo que tenemos es 7x por 10
por 7 x por 10,
y podemos cambiar estos términos de lugar y entonces llegamos a esta expresión de aquí
pero, cuando tenemos este símbolo de más,
las cosas se comportan de otra forma pero, bueno déjame borro todo esto
pero, bueno vamos a desarrollar esta expresión, esta multiplicación entre dos binomios.
Y para eso vamos a utilizar 2 veces la propiedad distributiva ¿Ok?
Tomemos este paréntesis entero
y los vamos a multiplicar por
7x y a eso le vamos a sumar este paréntesis por 10 y eso es simplemente
aplicar la propiedad distributiva y entonces lo que nos queda es el paréntesis
7x más 10 por 7x, por 7x más 10
10 por nuestro paréntesis que es 7x más 10,
y ahora vamos a volver a utilizar la propiedad distributiva en cada uno de estos paréntesis.
Tenemos que multiplicar 7x por cada uno de los elementos del paréntesis,
y también tenemos que multiplicar a este 10 por cada uno de los elementos que se están sumando
de este paréntesis, y entonces nos queda 7x por 7x eso es
49x cuadrada más
7x por 10 eso es
70x y por aquí nos queda 10 por 7x eso es
70x y finalmente 10 por 10
esos son 100.
Ahora algo muy interesante aquí, es que en esta expresión si tenemos a los términos
7x al cuadrado, que está por aquí, que es
49x cuadrada y al término 10 al cuadrado por que 10 al cuadrado es 100,
pero, también estamos sumando estas 2 cosas de aquí en medio pero,
podemos ver que cada una de estas 2 cosas
es lo que obtenemos si multiplicamos este término con este término.
¿Ok? 7x por 10 nos da
70x y tenemos 2 de estos términos por la forma en la que distribuimos estos paréntesis.
¿Ok? Este 70x proviene de multiplicar este 10
por este 7x, que a final de cuentas es este 10 por este 7x,
y este 70x proviene de multiplicar este 7x por este 10, que al fin y al cabo proviene de multiplicar
este 10 por este 7x pero, bueno al fin y al cabo lo que nos quedó es
49x cuadrada más
70x más 70x o sea 2 por 70x, que es
140 x más 100.
Ahora si necesitas hacer estas cuentas muy rápido y recuerda que todo esto
viene de la propiedad distributiva pero, bueno para hacerlo muy rápido
recuerda que es el primer término elevado al cuadrado, que está por aquí,
más la multiplicación de los dos términos,
multiplicado por un 2,
que está por acá, y finalmente el último término que es el otro término,
elevado al cuadrado que es éste de aquí.